hey guys so before talking about the
vector form for the quadratic
approximation of multivariable functions
I've got to introduce this thing called
the Hessian matrix Hessian matrix and
essentially what this is it's just a way
to package all the information of the
second derivatives of a function so
let's say you have some kind of multi
variable function like I don't know like
the example we had in the last video e
to the X halves multiplied by sine of Y
so some kind of multi variable function
what the hatching matrix is and it's
often denoted with an H where kind of a
bold-faced H is it's a matrix
incidentally enough that contains all
the second partial derivatives of F so
the first component is going to be the
partial derivative of F with respect to
X kind of twice in a row and everything
in this first column it's kind of like
you first do it with respect to X
because the next part is the second
derivative where first you do it with
respect to X and then you do it with
respect to Y so that's kind of the first
column of the matrix and then up here
it's the partial derivative where first
you do it with respect to Y and then you
do it with respect to X and then over
here it's where you do it with respect
to Y both times in a row so partial with
respect to Y both times in a row so
let's go ahead and actually compute this
and think about what this would look
like in the case of our specific
function here so in order to get all the
second partial derivatives we first
should just kind of keep a record of the
first partial derivatives so the partial
derivative of F with respect to X the
only place X shows up is in this e to
the X halves kind of bring down that 1/2
e to the X halves and sine of Y just
looks like a constant as far as X is
concerned sine of Y and then the partial
derivative with respect to Y partial
derivative of F with respect to Y now e
to the X halves looks like a constant
and it's being multiplied by something
that has a Y in it
e to the X halves and the derivative of
sine of Y since we're doing it with
respect to Y is cosine of Y cosine of Y
so these terms won't be included in the
Hessian itself but we're kind of just
kind of keeping a record of the
because now when we go in to fill in the
matrix this upper left component we're
taking the second partial derivative
where we do it with respect to X then X
again so up here's up here's when we did
it with respect to X if we did it with
respect to X again we kind of bring down
another half so that becomes 1/4 by e to
the X halves and that sine of Y just
still looks like a constant sine of Y
and then this mixed partial derivative
where we do it with respect to X then Y
so we did it with respect to X here when
we differentiate this with respect to Y
the 1/2 e to the X halves just looks
like a constant but then derivative of
sine of Y ends up as cosine of Y and
then up here it's going to be the same
thing but let's kind of see how it when
you do it in the other direction when
you do it first with respect to Y then X
so over here we did it first with
respect to Y if we took this derivative
with respect to X you'd have the half
would come down so that would be 1/2 e
to the X halves multiplied by cosine of
Y because that just looks like a
constant since we're doing it with
respect to X the second time so that
would be cosine of Y and it shouldn't
feel like a surprise that both of these
terms are now to be the same with most
functions that's the case technically
not all functions you can come up with
some crazy things where this won't be
symmetric where you'll have different
terms than the diagonal but for the most
part those you can kind of expect to be
the same and then this last term here
where we do it with respect to Y twice
we now think of taking the derivative of
this whole term with respect to Y that e
to the X halves looks like a constant
and derivative of cosine is negative
sine negative sine of Y so this whole
thing a matrix each of whose components
is a multivariable function is the
Hessian this is the Hessian of F and
sometimes people will write it as
Hessian of F kind of specifying what
function it's of and you could think of
this I mean you could think of it as a
matrix valued function which feels kind
of weird but you you know you plug in
two different values x and y and you'll
get a matrix so it's this matrix valued
function and the nice thing about
writing it like this is that you can
actually extend it so that rather than
just for functions that have two
variables let's say you had a function
you know kind of like
this up let's say you had a function
that had three variables or four
variables or kind of any number so let's
say it was you know a function of XY and
Z then you can follow this pattern and
following down the first column here the
next term that you would get would be
the second partial derivative of F where
first you do it with respect to X and
then you do it with respect to Z and
then over here it would be the the
second partial derivative of F where
first you did it with respect to first
you did it with respect to Y and then
you do it with respect to Z I'll clear
up even more room here because you'd
have another column where you'd have the
second partial derivative where this
time everything you know first you do it
with respect to Z and then with respect
to X and then over here you'd have the
second partial derivative where first
you do it with respect to Z and then
with respect to Y and then there's the
very last component you'd have the
second partial derivative where first
you do it with respect to well I guess
you do it with respect to Z twice so
this whole thing this three by three
matrix would be the Hessian of a three
variable function and you can see how
you could extend this pattern where if
it was a four variable function you get
a four by four matrix of all of the
possible second partial derivatives and
if it was a 100 variable function you
would have a 100 by 100 matrix so the
nice thing about having this is then we
can we can talk about that by just
referencing this symbol and we'll see in
the next video how this makes it very
nice to express for example the
quadratic approximation of any kind of
multi variable function not just a two
variable function and the symbols don't
get way out of hand because you don't
have to reference each one of these
individual components you can just
reference the matrix as a whole and
start doing matrix operations and I will
see you in that next video